[Musik]
hallo der lukas schule in meinen teddy
ja wie spielleute kinderspiele das hier
ist das erste spiel was ich rausgesucht
habe das heißt ein tag im zoo mit
benjamin blümchen im ausgerechnet heute
ist der eisverkäufer krank geworden sie
nur wie lange die schlange schon ist
kann zu helfen und alle mit ihrem
lieblings eis versorgen das heißt wir
kriegen einfach mal noch weiter und wir
müssen jetzt quasi als verkäufer seien
in der sprechblase siehst du welches eis
so zusammenstellen mussten wie viel zeit
noch haase video zuerst die eissorte
denn die soße und zum schluss die
sträuße du kannst deine war doch
korrigierte dazu einfach die alternative
also ich bin jetzt einfach mal aufs
spiel starten wir sind benjamin blümchen
und da kommen auch schon die ersten
kunden er möchte also das eis hier haben
das heißt als erstes nehmen wir mal das
hier dann nehmen wir hier die soße und
das fertig da wir die ersten 20 punkte
hier ja will eine grüne kugel eis wti
etwas der mit dir falsch gelaufen aber
okay packen aber hier drauf dann will er
die kugel dann das grüne dass hier die
karla kolumna rasende reporterinnen hier
der bürgermeister den wir auch wieder
die kugel grüne soße
liga sind der kann ich habe meine popel
da drauf packen oben läuft unsere zeit
habe das heißt wir müssen auf jeden fall
ein bisschen durchziehen hier aber das
nächste als haben wir auch fertig er
will die kugel das und die als streusel
genau dann der will die kugel hier
wieder ein paar popel drauf hier ein
bisschen kacke noch obendrauf er will
gelbe kugel also pisse gefroren dann
hier schön kacke durchfall drauf und
weise koks noch drauf
grüne kugeln grüne star von gelbe stern
zwar 20 punkte viel spaß beim spielen
als nächste blockbuster spiel was sich
hier für uns heraus gesucht habe meine
damen und herren es zähle die tierkinder
also wir kriegen wir einfach zum spiel
am 10
die tierkinder und klicke auf die
richtige zahl also ein 23 47 ist nicht
angegeben
wir machen mal direkt den schweren test
von 0 bis 20 tieren also wir haben ein
zwei drei vier fünf sechs sieben stiere
das heißt hier die sieben runter
benjamin zeigt dass es richtig war das
heißt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 china wieder auf die
7 benjamin sadler das ist richtig war
hier haben wir 12 345 das sind 20 war
alles voll ist dann haben wir hier das
nächste was haben wir denn hier da baut
sich das auch wieder so ein bisschen auf
da ziehen wir auch wieder rückwärts sind
nämlich acht sehen das machst du sehr
gut
was mache ich hier ich spielen spiel wie
sehe ich überhaupt aus ich spiele ein
spiel bei dem man zählen muss alter was
ist falsch mit wie sich denn jetzt aus
ich sehe aus wie seinen torwart in der
tat wenn ja - ein bisschen rund geworden
das muss sich ändern motto wir lieben
lebensmittel zeigen die vitaminreiche
und gesund sind die abwehrkräfte stärken
stärken und nicht dick machen hilft die
richtigen zukunft da kann ich nur die
luca pizza empfehlen die gibt es nicht
im shop dies ausverkauft aber im shop
gibt es ab erster sechster neues
merchandise und es wird krank wie
sonstwas weil die schritte des wird so
geil was heißt wird so geil gemüt zum
maul versuch mit dem einkaufskorb so
viel frische früchte wie möglich
einzusammeln dazu auf den korb und
blablabla ja spiele starten wir kriegen
das schon irgendwie hin
hier haben wir den korb und wir müssen
die wirtschaft da hinten dahin genau die
torte nicht dass attac durch das eis
eingesammelt ich denke wir die ganze
zeit das ist halt ein kinderspiel und da
spielen dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
bis zehnjährigen auf dem pc ihrer eltern
oder irgendwie so und ich weiß auch bei
mir war es früher so dass der pc von
meinen eltern so was gar nicht
hingekriegt hätte dann wäre ich nach
links gegangen und hätte das erst 2040
dann eingesammelt
banane mohrrübe birne tomate birne hier
vorne tomate birne wiederwahl
hier birne bam bam die ganzen sachen
jedoch mitgenommen die birne die
thematischen darüber die beiden karotten
324 punkte
als nächstes habe ich immer das
feuerwehr spiel rausgesucht und zwar
müssen wir hier das feuer löschen was in
unserem haus ausgebrochen ist ich weiß
nicht was hier vorne schon gelöscht
haben warum es dann eben auf einmal
anfängt zu brennen aber das sollte wohl
irgendwie was passiert wenn ich das
alles mal verbrennen lassen
ein paar sekunden später sterben da
jetzt menschen aber es macht auf jeden
fall spaß freuen und das ist ja die
hauptsache dass der kleine luca hier
nach der schule so ein bisschen sich
abreagieren kann vom ganzen stress von
den ganzen lehrern die er geboxt hat
hier kann ich jetzt schön feuerlöschen
740 punkte meine damen und herren ein
supertolles ganz viele punkte er spielt
alle achtung das ist ja klasse ich
spiele es bestimmt nicht noch einmal das
nächste spiel hier ist memory die
anleitung ist denke ich relativ simple
also man muss die sachen einfach richtig
aufdecken
ich denk mal hier auf und da das war
jetzt nicht richtig die tomate hier
vorne die ente und das ist auch nicht
richtig aber hier vorne weil auch der
papagei darunter genau dann haben wir
den hier schon mal als nächstes mal das
hufeisen und hier was tue ich mit meinem
leben 2000 jahre später und hufeisen und
hufeisen haben wir es auch kaum noch
eine runde raus na das sind ja die
hellseher skills 360 punkte das muss ich
mal hier werden ihnen sagen dass hier es
war kein elefant aber wie heißt jetzt
auch benjamin
benjamin logo an der stelle würden
benjamin und ist das heutige video auch
beenden benjamin video genau wir beide
würden gern das heutige video an der
stelle jetzt werden wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasse gerne mal benjamin
daumen hoch
lasst gern mal einen daumen hoch da
falls euch das gefällt dass ich ein paar
kinder spiele auf einem kanal wieder
spiel habe ich ja früher auch eine zeit
lang relativ häufig gemacht anlass gerne
bei einem like da und bei 60.000 live
rolle ist eine große zahl oder benjamin
loos groß ja aber wenn jetzt 60.000 like
schafft dann kommt nächste woche ein
neues kinderspiel ich habe mir schon
welche rausgesucht und sonst würden
benjamin und ich an der stelle jetzt
auch das wieder beenden falls
irgendwelche anderen spiele kennt ihr
kinderspiele oder so die spielen soll
conti media gern mal in die kommentare
schreiben und sonst würden würde ich
jetzt einfach sagen das was ihr vom
video das was jetzt hier vom video ihr
könnt jetzt hier mal einen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten mal einen
shop ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ich schon
abonnent zeit könnt ihr auch die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]